In fact,
no matter what the care setting,
without electronic assistance,
physicians often don't coordinate well.
The Commonwealth Fund
surveys patients like Marla.
In 2011 they found that,
quote, to varying degrees in
all countries chronically ill or
sicker patients encounter
failures of providers to communicate
with each other or coordinate care.
Yet in each country, patients with
primary care practices that help them
navigate the care system and
provide easy access are far less
likely to encounter duplication delays
and failures to share information.
Unsaid here is that almost all patients
in patient-centered practices,
shown in red here,
are using electronic records.
And you can see that they have lower,
actually significantly lower,
reported rates of care
coordination problems.